Kristen is in North Carolina hi Kristen
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much for your help
thank you for calling how can I help
well my husband and I are wondering
whether or not we should be filing for
bankruptcy we just got over headed on
everything and we have a creditor who is
now suing us we just got the notice
about that a few days ago so we were
looking at bankruptcy but then the same
day I was looking into things and I
found your show and I've seen you help
people with numbers that seemed to be a
lot worse than ours I just don't really
know you know what's the best decision
for us on that yeah
it just scares the crud out of you and
somebody Sue's you didn't it she has
never happened before and we're just
flabbergasted I understand okay so tell
me about the lawsuit who's it with
it's with Discover Bank okay so credit
card it was it was a loan a bank loan
okay how much was the bank loan 15,000
okay and how long has it been since you
paid them our last payment we made in
April Wow
I came after you quick to show you and
they've actually filed a court date um
there's not a court date on it what we
received was a similar civil summons and
a bunch of papers proving the debt and
things like that okay and where is
Discover Bank where are they located um
oh no it's not an actual Bank chain I'm
sorry I said Discover Bank it's discover
the big credit card company but this is
a loan not a credit card oh okay okay
good yeah that's good news okay and
what's your household income our
take-home is 50,000 okay and how much
other that have you got not counting
your house well we don't have a house we
rent and including that
loan are all together debt is 90,000
okay so you've got 75 of other stuff
what is that
well that's 7,000 left on the car loan
7,000 left on a student loan and then
various other credit cards and poor
decisions loans things like that and
both of you work 40 hours I work
part-time but that's because the nature
of my job is that the work comes and
goes I'm in freelance ok and what is
your income mine averages out to about
24,000 take-home hey Johnny so he works
40 hours and makes 25,000 yes what's he
do he makes less than I do
he works in IT why is he not paid any
more than that naughty oh because his
company is the worst and they haven't
given him a raise in four years what
does he does he do a naughty
well he's responsible for so he works
with the clients at the company who need
to convert their phone lines over to a
company paid program he's literally the
only person who does this and he
survives five layoffs in the past five
years but they're not obviously not
giving raises because they're laying
people off well I mean North Carolina in
general has got a lot of Technology
stuff going on I'm surprised he can't
make double what he's making doing
something similar somewhere else as he
looked well he doesn't have a degree
problem most people in technology don't
have a degree
yeah you gotta know how to flip the
switches that's it mm-hmm looking
because you know I got 300 people on my
team that are technology people and
varying degrees of what they do from
software to hardware to whatever and I
don't have
single one of them making 24,000 and
phonelines stuff included so you know hi
and I'm not saying that we're
necessarily a better employer although
we probably are but the point is is that
I think he's under I think he's
underpaid I think and he's looking for a
job because income Wow income will help
you guys can you kick your hours up and
kick your jobs up what do you do well I
do freelance I teach English to Chinese
kids
so um English as a second language yes
English is a second language so it's
it's something that you know they come
to me so I'm kind of at the mercy of who
wants classes when kind of thing except
you could find more people that wanted
the classes if you went out and scoured
the land a little bit because I mean if
we could change your all's income twenty
thousand dollars a year it would change
this whole picture very quickly you
follow me yeah I think you guys haven't
concentrated on the end on your careers
and on the income side of your equation
and that's part of what I mean you're
not you're not you're not blowing money
out of your you know just crazy amounts
of money somewhere you're not just
wasted money you've you're under
employed you're not making a ton between
the two of you and you've been
disorganized and those two things
together or no shame or no sin that's
just normal human stuff right but those
are the two things we can fix we can get
you organized to get your income up and
I think you can turn this around really
really quickly
mm-hmm that would be great yeah let's
just place it with some math for a
second let's pretend we took ten
thousand of your current income and you
had it twenty two it like I'm talking
about by him getting a better job and
you'd working more and then all of a
sudden that's thirty thousand bucks that
we throw at that if I got ninety and I
throw thirty at it I'm done in three
years yeah and in the meantime I've
dealt with these morons that discover
and I gave them a big check of some kind
of settle this debt because I would
imagine if you called them and offered
them about seven thousand dollars cash
right now they probably take it for that
debt but you don't have seven thousand
dollars cash we got to scrape that
together right right mm-hmm so let's
get you on a written budget on every
dollar go to every dollar comm and
download that better than that I'm just
gonna put you two into Financial Peace
University and that includes the every
dollar plus which except to your bank
we're gonna pay for all of it and we'll
give it to you okay if I give it to you
will you go will you go to the class if
I give it to you oh absolutely I would
okay ahem - you got taking them with you
okay now we're also guys I'm also going
to send you a copy of Ken Coleman's book
the proximity principle on careers
because the career thing is part of your
all's equation so Financial Peace
University is going to show you exactly
what to do with money step by step how
to get control how to get this wrapped
up how to get it in the moving in the
right direction and then you guys have
got to work your butts off and get your
incomes up and when you do those two
things together we can get rid of this
stupid lawsuit in a matter of a couple
of months by just saving up some money
real real fast by working our butts off
living on nothing beans and rice rice
and beans you're not gonna see the
inside of a restaurant less you're
working there and don't talk to me about
a vacation you're broken getting sued
yeah no yeah this is game on but yeah
this is game on okay and I agree you can
do it you can do it I know you can do it
and I'm gonna be here for you if you
need some more help you call me back any
time but you hold on and Kelly's gonna
pick up we're gonna give you Financial
Peace University for the one-year
membership and the nine week class and
we're gonna give you the proximity
principle book which will take care of
helping you guys with your careers both
of you because you need to get this
these things moving in your life
congratulations
you can really change your life it's
gonna be very tough tough year coming up
but it's gonna be a lot the good news is
there's gonna be a bright bright future
on the other end of it so hey good
question thank you for joining us